la esencia del parlamento está también
quebrada en nuestro país no se entiende
las instituciones del perú tiene un
problema grave de big daddy's opcional a
diferencia de otros países incluso en la
región donde a pesar de sus problemas a
veces parecidos a los peruanos la
fortaleza de las instituciones es
bastante mayor
señor realice esta toda esta polémica
alrededor de pedro castillo hacen
preguntarse algo y es una pregunta que
le trasladó de terminar a pedro castillo
su mandato
todo indica que no los razonables que no
con lo que ha sucedido en los últimos
días aparte de lo que usted ha dicho a
los dos intentos de vacancia por el
congreso las cinco investigaciones
fiscales en curso los escándalos
adicionales en torno a sus funcionarios
y también a sus familiares y en la
reciente entrega de su ex secretario del
despacho presidencial
parece que tiene mucha información sobre
supuestos delitos en los que habría
participado el presidente esto ocurrió
hace dos días no la eventualidad de la
próxima entrega de su ex ministro de
transportes comunicaciones en la misma
línea yo creo que pone en peligro y a su
mandato